Joining us right now is ocean explorer Tom
Detwiler, he led the team that found the wreckage
of the titanic, is also a close friend with
ph nargeolet one of the people on board the
missing vessel.
What are your new thoughts on this reporting
that we were talk being with Miguel Marquez
of search crews picking up repeated banging
sounds via sonar devices.
Does that give you hope?
>> Well, like everybody, you want to hold
out hope until there can be no more hope.
The banging sounds are interesting because
knowing ph nargeolet and his experience with
submersibles and his background in submarines
this is exactly how he would try to indicate
that they were still alive and try to communicate
with surface.
He would do some banging, do it on a neg lar
schedule so that it was dishable from the
background
[9:06:08 AM]
was dishable from the background noises that
are in the ocean all the time.
So it is encouraging that there did seem to
be a pattern to it and, you know, we are going
to continue to hold out hope.
>> Absolutely.
Tom, is that -- do you think that that would
be -- you said that would be exactly what
he would be doing.
Is that, do you think, ph would be improvising
or is this some sort of, I don't know, standard
protocol or procedure that you're familiar
of when it comes to underwater emergencies?
>> It is a standard protocol for contacting
any sort of rescue service that might be coming
your way.
>> That is super interesting.
You've described ph as a close -- as a close
friend.
I want to play for you, Tom, what another
ocean explorer David Gallo said about P.H.
On CNN last night.
Let me play this for you.
>> If P.H.
Nargeolet was sitting here with me like he
normally would be, this is what he would say
to do, let's just sit down
[9:07:09 AM]
say to do, let's just sit down together in
a small room, figure out what needs to be
done and let's make it happen, let's do it.
>> Tom, what do you think P.H.
Would be saying right now?
>> It would be exactly that.
He is very calm, collected, expert in his
field and, you know, we would have approached
this in a very scientific manner, very straightforward
manner and just get the fastest reaction out
there that we could have.
I've spent the last two days trying to get
an effort out there, it's on its weiwei now
and I know that P.H.
Would have done the same thing for anybody
else out there, whether he knew them or not.
The community would have drawn together just
like you've seen it over the last couple days
and we would do anything in our power to get
out there.
Never questioning costs, never questioning
time, you know, just do it.
Drop everything.
>> Tom, talk to me about the effort and what
you're trying to
[9:08:10 AM]
effort and what you're trying to get out there
and what you've seen that's been deployed
so far.
Talk to me about the scope and scale and what
they're also up against in terms of trying
to find them and get to them.
>> Well, some of the experts have already
said that, you know, you see Navy assets going
out there, that's very important because the
Navy assets that are currently on their way
are the assets that are experienced in finding
things under water and doing recoveries from
very deepwater.
Some of the few assets that are available
and they will get there within the next day
or so.
That's the limitation is it's very far out
there and, you know, just getting this very
heavy equipment moving, get it to where it
needs to be, mobilizing it on the ship, as
you can imagine, when a ship goes out to sea
everything has to be fastened down so you're
doing a lot of welding and things like that
to make sure that it stays in place as the
ship starts to roll in the seas, and then,
you know, it has to be able to take the load
if you're doing a recovery.
[9:09:11 AM]
doing a recovery.
So there's a lot of work that has to be done,
but these are all guys who do this routinely
and they do it quickly and I think that you
will see some success in finding it quickly.
>> Where is your heart and head on this right
now?
I know you said that you want to hold out
hope because you've got to hold out hope for
another day, you also know the realities of
the risks and the dangers down there.
I mean, you've -- you probably know it better
than anybody.
>> My whole career has been in the very deep
ocean and I do know all the things that can
happen and I've run over all those in my head.
But I've seen miracles happen at sea as well,
very unexpected things, very surprising things.
So I'm going to continue to hold out hope.
They still have some oxygen left and you have
to consider that the oxygen estimates are
based on normal activities in the sub.
One thing P.H.
Would have done is tried to calm everybody
down and keep them quiet so that
[9:10:11 AM]
and keep them quiet so that they're using
less oxygen.
You can potentially extend that beyond the
estimates.
>> Tom, I can't -- that's super important
to consider in all of this and thank you so
much for coming on, having your level of expertise
and also just to hear about your friendship
with P.H.
And what you know he would be doing down there
right now is really important for everybody.
Thank you so much, Tom.
>> You're quite welcome, Kate.
>> John?
>> That was a great discussion.
>>> This morning we have a firsthand account
of what it is like to take part in this kind
of underwater adventure.
One year ago Simpson's writer Mike Reese was
on the same submersible that is missing in
the atlantic.
He told a CNN affiliate about the dangers
he proo prepared for ahead of the trip and
explained the navigational issues his team
experienced during the dive.
>> It was just 11 months ago in this very
same sub and I see over and over on every
dive we
[9:11:15 AM]
over and over on every dive we took they lost
communication.
This is just one of the problems with this
thing.
You know, I'm sure the world is very worried
and that kind of thing, but something to know
having gone through it is you know going in
how very dangerous this is.
It's not any bad reflection on -- on Stockton
rush, it's his company and he designed it,
but it's just that we are all part of this
ongoing experiment.
Before you even get on you sign this long,
long waiver that mentions possible death three
times on the first page.
So you know what you're getting into.
In fact, when I stepped on to the sub I just
-- you know, part of my mind was going, well,
this could be the end.
>> Wow.
[9:12:17 AM]
>> So that -- I mean, mostly, you know, it's
a very creepy feeling to think if they're
alive, down at the bottom of the ocean or
something like that and, you know, just knowing
I don't think there is a way to get them out
of the situation like that and that they will
just be sitting there for three or four days
before the oxygen runs out, very scary thought.
>> Scary indeed.
I did note, Sara, he said that every dive
they took they lost communication.
So people who are involved with